welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question
mera Bowl the show that gives you too
much information about how Christopher
Nolan will melt our brains or you know
maybe already has melted them and now
he's like I'm melting them into solid
state so we can like unsure a bullet
through it me up I'm Eric Weiss here
with me is Tommy Bechtold have I already
lost you buddy is this already too
confusing we're gonna need one of these
all the way through it because this is
this is a head scratcher this is a bit
confusing good hit me with that big
question time talking about time we're
talking about Tennant you know somebody
once told me time is a flat circle
everything we've ever done over and over
[Music]
so my question for you is how does time
inversion work in Tennant Tommy I just
got lost in your flat circle ran and and
then I realized time is a flat circle
bridging both true detective and
interstellar it's the same guy just
repeating it rough coal is a also a
brilliant scientist slash pilot slash
whatever it was Matthew McConaughey's
character did he's everything he's an
and a great dad what a Swiss Army knife
well tenant of course is Chris Nolan's
newest film it is confirmed to open in
theaters social distancing be damned and
how looks like it could be the biggest
movie of 2020 maybe this year's
inception this year's Dark Knight this
could be the only movie we actually but
good thing is that we can just run it
back and run it forward
you know shooting the bullet you're
catching it yeah there's there's enough
to talk about because it deals with this
thing called time inversion and rather
than you know spend this whole movie
trying to play catch-up as we're saving
this theater trying not to breathe we
want to help all of us go in a little
prepared so we could just like try to
enjoy the story and just see the cool
ways that this concept is applied and I
have tried my best to explain it in
breakdowns of the past two trailers to
be honest it's a bit confusing and we'll
probably revisit this when the movie
comes out and laughing well Nolan based
time inversion on a thermodynamics
concept of entropy he said and I'll
quote him here in his mixed British and
American accent because he because he's
both turned into James with time in the
different ways in which time can
function not to get into a physics
lesson but in version is this idea of
material that has had its entropy
inverted so it's running backwards
through time relative to us that's about
right that's right let's quickly explain
the physics of this and we're gonna use
my least favorite trip to introduce it a
good ol in English please in English
please okay so let's go through this
entropy is the measure of disorder in
the universe so all particles in the
universe are moving toward a
thermodynamic equilibrium a balance of
maximum disorder that's intro pain love
that maximum disorder they broke when it
comes to body building muscle mass can
neither be created nor destroyed the
second law of thermodynamics states that
entropy cannot be reversed it's always
increasing it cannot decrease over time
because that's just the way the universe
works but Nolan that all trickster has
created a theoretical world in which
certain objects have had their entropy
inverted so that they are moving
backwards in time relative to us things
like weapons the
chuckles people now before Nolan
confirmed it you could actually see this
into that on the dry erase board in one
of the trailers there are equations
those are the laws of thermodynamics and
there's this diagram showing Maxwell's
thought experiment Maxwell was a
physicist who came up with a concept of
Maxwell's demon
don't get scared Tommy I'm so confused
that fear is the last thing I feel like
I've like I'm one of those people
plunging into the ocean that was just
accepted the icy grave that I'm falling
into now the confusion has overtaken the
field and soon the sweet bliss of death
will follow imagine instead of going
into a body of water you are trapped in
one of two chambers
this is Maxwell's thought experiment
when you interview one of these chambers
has blue particles those represent
slower colder particles another has red
particles those are faster hotter
particles and right in the middle of
those two is a door with a demon
controlling it and that demon can open
and close the door between the chambers
to segregate the particles thereby
violating the second law of
thermodynamics decreasing inverting
entropy in real life those those
particles will mix and you know they'll
reach an equilibrium but the demon has
special divine insight into each
particles direction it's velocity all of
its variables and can kind of control
all this in order to like freeze the
universe in the way he wants to that's
what basically the thought experiment is
the demon doesn't exist but he said
theoretically things like entropy could
get inverted in addition to entropy
another natural law is time time is
always going forward it's like a
manufactured way that we read the
universe but it's another one of these
things that like entropy it could get
inverted if that demon existed tidy me a
time demon if you will as opposed to a
time bandit which is a delightful little
person now I didn't just waste your time
Tommy because this is actually important
as we could tell from the trailer
footage there actually appears to be one
of these chambers in the movie Nolan
built this into his movie there's this
like concrete chamber that keeps showing
up there are two sides and if you look
at the floor closely there's one that's
marked red one side smoked blue and
there is this
valdine door in between it and that wall
in between these might represent a kind
of like nexus between parallel realities
each side is a different reality with
opposite entropies opposite time
movement okay and also we'll see if this
related but the kid in the movie that
Elizabeth deBakey's character is seen
with is reported to be named max which
could be a nod to Maxwell's demon
we'll see we'll check in in a couple
weeks on that okay so right now Tommy
and I are on the red side we're moving
forward in time but there exists whoa
Eric and Tommy down on the blue side
they're moving the reverse from our
perspective wait listen how you guys
doing down there
sneer we're weird but you guys sound
real crazy over there this is weird wait
mine is now moving a different direction
that's strange from cook to cook like a
Bellagio fountain all this makes me want
to do is gamble baby
maybe it's the playing cards maybe it's
my own personal demon Tommy's demon that
lives in my heart tells me to gamble
I spilled so much water on me then it
looks like I peed my pants
I'm wet for a very different reason baby
because those two everything about me
but not me and opposite you was real fun
too yes he's a load of fun you know what
he doesn't drink Coors Light he drinks
coolers original the banquet beer okay
let's get back to the same Buran tenant
that revolving door appears to be the
demon door and it looks like it's used
to transfer weapons and vehicles people
through to the other side now those
transfer things have inverted entropy
once they get on the other side so how
is this applied in the movie tenants
okay I'm gonna do my best here objects
come from the other side but they retain
their inverted entropy in our world so
guns from the other side they don't fire
bullets they catch bullets that have
already been fired now how do those fire
bullets get there for them to be caught
I think we could assume that they were
fired by the parallel doppelganger gun
from our side and then you bring in the
other side gun and it inverts the shot
to catch the bullet so does that make
sense yeah but so does that mean that
the two parallel
beings are working in concert with each
other so you would somehow communicate
to your other self and another dimension
to fire a gun at a certain access point
so that you could then catch it maybe
maybe not maybe the altar itself already
knows that that bullet was fired so the
gun goes through and it's just one
person on one side using that inverted
gun maybe they go and they steal that
gun so that they can invert it and like
with people by using this inversion that
they're not expecting and we see an
example this in the prologue scene that
was released in IMAX showings in in
December John David Washington's
character is saved in this Opera House
hostage situation when a bullet that was
already fired in the floor is inverted
back into a gun behind him it goes
through an enemy that's standing between
that nested bullet and the gun the gun
that caught the shot had inverted
entropy in this environment the shooter
of that gun in the mystery man who runs
away lined up the enemy in front of a
shot that was previously fired and then
used his reverse gun to catch that
bullet through him Wow are we still I
get to work with my favorite guy me yeah
now in the trailer footage it's not just
it's not just weapons there's all kinds
of tools that can be used for this like
it looks like rappelling hooks so
whereas before those hooks were used to
rappel down the side of a building it
seems like the inverted ones are used to
zip them up whatever floor they need to
get back up to they use the inverted
version that was repelled previously on
the other side to invert back up now now
this also works with cars
you've probably seen the crazy car chase
imagery from the trailer if you look in
that chamber there is a car that's
nested there that's probably gonna be
transferred to the other side that
diamond door is big enough to move cars
and other vehicles through so they bring
the car from the other side to our side
and they use that cars reverse entropy
that's why they have to drive it
backwards on the route that it's double
previously took so the only the car is
moving in Reverse entropy and they're
taking it back to its point of origin
and they're doing that because along
this route there's like things that they
need to do they can revisit whatever
past moment they need to revisit maybe
intercept someone maybe kill someone
maybe save someone on that Highway it
also looks and this is where might get
even crazier people themselves can go
through the store to the other side in
which case the whole world to you would
look inverted right also if you do that
it looks like you have to bring an
oxygen tank with you because the air
particles on the other side - you are
unbreathable they're reverse particle
acceleration makes it impossible for
your bloodstream to absorb that oxygen
so you needed to bring in home oxygen
with you kind of like when we all go on
flights right now we don't want to
breathe the air that's there you got to
bring the air that it came from he was
just trying to tell us bring your own
air this guy nuke Ovid was coming
decades before my god Howard Dean said
he is the inverted Howard Dean he had
drawn in that universe he's president he
may be yeah who knows maybe in another
timeline I'm the boy King I got cold I
would - okay bye little boy young boy
you're always my boy King in any
universe just so you know boy King
always boinkin now the craziest version
of this that we've seen so far in the TV
promo other than the car chases there's
like a shot of ancients hijacking a
plane but doing it on the ground
so the plane has already crashed and
exploded on the ground they are now in
their alternate like world where time is
inverted they're sneaking on that plane
as the fire is reverse extinguished by
firefighters right to the point before
the plane explodes so that they can be
that plane before its destruction
without anyone noticing I am very very
sneaky sir so that's how they hijack it
they hijack it on the ground so that
they can get back to the air brilliant
yes
now despite discussing this full concept
to the best of our ability we don't know
what the hell this movie is about we
know the mission we we don't know what
the heist is it's hard to know the
objective of all this it's kind of like
trying to process Nolan's inception
dream logic without knowing the point of
that heist you Incept
and someone's dream like if you didn't
know that you're just like well how did
dreams work and then I'll try to work
backwards that's what we're doing here's
the little we do know we do know John
David Washington's characters trying to
prevent a global catastrophe that is
supposedly worse than World War three
he's working with Robert Pattinson we
know Kenneth Branagh is probably the bad
guy he's got a strange wife played by
Elizabeth de vikke and they're connected
to this we also know Aaron
taylor-johnson is gonna play a major
role he showed up very briefly barely
recognizable as a soldier in the second
trailer but Nolan has been very very
cryptic about what his role is kick-ass
he's chemically kick-ass again oh yeah
and see that did you know John Leonard
he's gonna roll from nowhere boy it was
it was funny it was great we also know
that Washington's agent role is
codenamed a protagonist which is
something that I predicted back in my
first trailer breakdown I'm very proud
I'm if there's neighs a little sure but
enough now based off of my pure
speculation
I think it's possible - Branagh could be
an entropy terrorists who like maybe
hijack system version tech to unravel
time only because the word Tennant is a
palindrome derived from the famous latin
state or square found in the ruins of
pompei it's a two-dimensional palindrome
grid matrix with a mysterious meaning
the histories have been able to decode
maybe Briana's character has this
ancient relic with inverted entropy that
he's gonna use to rewind time back to
ancient times to undo peak historical
events throughout history people
described this as the musical the last
five years but with action which as a
musical theater nerd
that makes a lot of sense to me I think
we're we're all just gonna sound pretty
stupid in a couple weeks so we'll have
to you know reverse time back to this
God find out that John David
Washington's character is the grandson
of Emperor Palpatine I feel like this
movie's gonna be well ahead of its
competition yep
the bar has been set pretty low lately
by Hollywood hadn't it well we wanted to
thank our friends from Korres for
helping sponsor this episode look the
summer is gonna be a very different one
as you can see there's a whole lot of
stuff you can't do before school starts
this fall festivals concerts movies
they're good and push back or they're
getting change but you know what that
doesn't mean summer is canceled Coors
Light wants to help you chill this
summer and take a break from all the
stresses and pressures of daily life you
know who's gonna be chilling this over
with Coors Light my uncle Doug that man
has had a refrigerator full of Coors
Light since I have known him which is
now I don't know how old am i 24 years
old so I've been for three years she's
been sharing his Coors Light with me so
you know who's not canceling this summer
with Coors like my uncle Doug he will be
enjoying Coors Light and you know what I
think we can all follow an uncle Doug's
example because you know there are just
some days where I go up to my apartment
balcony and I want to look over at my
neighbor crack open of course like you
must be like right yeah hey that's life
huh yeah but we're here and we're
chilling out and that's great cool he
drives motorcycles and smokes secret
cigarettes in the garage so my husband
find out big secret cigs actually
there's a new Coors Light summer can
that does the work for you it features
sunglasses that literally turn blue and
the beer is cold and ready to drink
I can't wait to crack up more of those
Tommy's ready to cold I'm icy cold
of course late it's a perfect beer for
chillin as it's cold crisp in just a
hundred five calories Wow
and that's why Coors Light is the one I
choose when I need a moment of chill so
when do you need to reset the summer
reach for the beer that's made to chill
you can have Coors Light delivered by
going to get doc Coors Light calm and
fine
a local delivery option near you
celebrate responsibly Coors Brewing
Company Golden Colorado Cheers
all right let's move on to some
bite-sized questions that Tommy's gonna
answer you ready yeah
all right our friend Ned on this chord
asked in a venture sin game why did dr.
strange just take the gauntlet himself
teleport into a safe location to perform
the snap himself or just like bring Tony
with him to do it good question
and you know at first like most things I
said I agree a little bit of
investigating and I remembered some
things and again as in life is often the
case with me I was let's not forget that
dr. Stephen strangers I call steve-o
Knievel had his hands full during the
final battle of endgame if you recall he
was preventing people from drowning by
holding back so that for one is almost
an excuse enough on itself but don't
forget that Stephen strange went and saw
like literally millions of possible
outcomes there was only one that was
successful so he knew that if it was
going to be him unless he was lying in
there were two that were successful he
just didn't want to die just one
possible scenario were successful Tony
had to be the one to make the sacrifice
let's not forget that Tony is the one
that had to mark 85 armor that would be
able to absorb the stones from Thanos so
really ultimately it comes down to the
right tech and the right person who had
the right amount of available bandwidth
at that time or energy to expend to to
get the stones and had to be Tony yeah
and the right uh the right amount of
time left on its contract as well which
is not exactly an actor who probably
doesn't want to have to do all that
physical work anymore as they age their
late 50s oh god wait there yeah and we
have another bite-sized question from
who texts on Twitter I'm a cleaner rung
and Wonder Woman 84 when diana ejects
the bullet and then
punches it away is the bullet traveling
fast enough to still be deadly that's an
interesting question well you know I
like this question a lot and I have a
split answer I believe that there are
two scenarios one in which the bullet
would be deadly and one in which the
bullet would not be pierce skin with
braces of submission that Wonder Woman
wears those are made of metals so
usually what we know from baseball we
know that when a metal bat hits the ball
the exit speed that it comes off is
about twenty miles an hour faster than
with which the the ball is coming in so
a 90 mile an hour pitch will leave off
the bat at 110 miles an hour for Yunnan
sports fans
we can take a look at the gun so you
pierce skin a bullet needs to go about
20 feet per second a normal handgun has
a muzzle velocity when the board is
leaving the chamber of about 1,500 feet
per second so that's plenty so if the
bullet was actually exiting the gun at
that point when it goes up through the
chamber if it had been fired already
it would deflect off the bracelet of
submission at a speed of like 1,700 feet
per second and easily kill someone
however from what I could tell it does
not look as if the gun had been fired
yet simply it looks as though the bullet
is being soft tossed at the air and if
we're using the baseball analogy that a
soft toss is you know if you throw your
own ball up in the air it's about maybe
40 miles an hour maybe 50 miles an hour
so that bullet is only going up if she
hits that with a metal bracelet even
with a really strong fast swing you know
like a Barry Bonds or a Gary Sheffield
swing or a Mike Trout for your younger
kids even if Peter Lanza was taking a
hack with the process of submission it's
still only leaving at about 70 miles per
hour not enough to pierce skin and
unless the person just does a terrible
fear of bullets and drops dead of a
heart attack I will say that bullet did
not kill someone in that truck my answer
is no Wow Tommy you put so many great
visuals in my head of these baseball
players wearing the bracelets of
submission I do John if you're out there
if you could give people onso what a
Wonder Woman outfit I will real make me
very happy
great a wonderful job Tommy we now have
time for one more question that we're
gonna go to box scraps just a little
[Music]
dirty question that we're gonna find out
some unknowable things on the itami all
right this person asks what is a basic
thing you never learned how to do that
at this point you will never learn I'll
go first
mine is all to do with loops I have
three different looping exercises that I
never I learned shortcut fast ways to do
them someone must have taught me as a
frustrated adult when I was a little kid
then I have never learned the right way
to do the first is tying my shoes I know
there's a like round the corner through
the loop in but there's also the very
easy with your hands make two loops tie
them together they're tight
second thing is tying a tie there's like
you know winter not double Windsor all
those things yes people can make ties
you know look beautiful on them I do the
most basic like this is kind of an
octonaut ends up being about the size of
a cherry and then the neck is just
massive I always kind of looked like
like a Dick Tracy gangster he's too big
on me which is shocking that they even
have fabric to do that but the last
thing and perhaps the most shameful
thing that I don't know how to do is
write in cursive and I will tell you why
when I was in I believe first grade
which is when we started to learn how to
write cursive I was really sick and I
missed a lot of school and I just never
learned how to write in cursive and
right around that time is when they kind
of decided that cursive wasn't that
important from handwriting was kind of
going out the window most people had
word processors at least or things they
could type up most papers were expected
to be handed in typed up from almost
that point on so at least to where I
went to school in Rochester New York but
I never really learned how to write
cursive and I've always just kind of
faked it like I kind of know about half
of the letters is that not
Marta felt like I can probably I mean
capitalized I can do them all but like
there are specific ones like for a
million dollars I couldn't write a
cursive G for you right now I can't
cursive T the cursive Z's the weird one
the cursive Z looks like a three yeah
three that like this drunk and goes
under the line myself is a freaking
[ __ ] here I don't I tie shoes or write
cursive correctly but they do trust me
to drive a car so so it just sounds like
to me correct me if I'm wrong Tommy you
never learned how to tie your shoes
dress yourself or read or write nice
that that will be what someone takes
away from this I I read I put read in
there because I can only assume yeah I
definitely can't read I never clean
completely understandable Tommy
Diana ties hard I had to do this thing I
do the half windsor and then I just like
try to stretch it out for me there are
two things I heard the long stem I could
not properly high five because I was not
athletic in high school but then I
learned the trick of you Lee aim for the
elbow works every time but I still can't
do the the non handshake non high five
just like cool guys yes you in that
thing I always awkward for me and then
you know sometimes well not nowadays
thank god this is like the best time of
my life because no one's doing that but
like just that simple thing and I always
end up making it a hug so like people
just be like hey man and I'm like don't
do this at me do this or do that you
don't come in and do one of these cuz
I'll always just be like and then now
we're hugging we're we're just hugging
we're hugging or were more than friends
absolutely there's a real sweet spot of
like when you're in your 20s and your
dad and his friends are in their 50s and
his friends are all want to be really
cool towards you so they will not just
give you a gentleman's handshake they're
like I gotta come at this kid and show
him that I am down that I get how kids
shake hands and then you just end up
like we're the caressing your father's
friend's hand your eyes the next thing
you know that is cabin by the lake the
Sun is setting and you got a cup of
Coors lights and yeah and you think well
whatever
I'm not letting summer be canceled on me
I'm here and I'm having fun and it all
started with a weird handshake so it all
starts with a weird handshake oh there's
one more thing I never learned how to do
with roller skate I can't escape but I
can I love trying to escape during like
winter season but I Smith I never
learned how to roller skate I hate that
feeling not having like a firm footing
and as a kid there's a period of middle
school where everyone has roller rink
birthday parties and I was always a kid
who's like I better bring a bunch of
quarters because I'm gonna be hanging
out in the arcade yeah so the last one
of those I went to was my buddy Terry it
was like his 12th birthday and he was uh
it was at a roller rink and I just got
bored I ran out of quarters so I would
like just like hang out on the side and
like wave to my friends and try to do
bits with them because I'm like who
knows it's gonna end at what point this
this stranger kid rolls up next to me
and he's like hey why aren't you skating
and I go oh I am I can't really skate he
goes oh I'll teach you and I said no
it's fine i-i've tried it before I'm
gonna be leaving soon but thanks and
he's like are you sure he's like all
right sweetest kid in the world and just
keep skating and then like then I
started get really bored I just started
racing Terry on the side and I was
running and I'd be like I bet I could
beat you and at one point I had to like
sidestep this kid earlier who who
offered to teach me and and I I like
kind of cut him off and almost costume
trip and he goes hey and I literally
turn her out I basically said whatever
the eleven-year-old equivalent was of
God was so mean to him and then and then
he ran all the way around the track and
like five minutes later this big scary
kid comes up to me and he goes hi did
you mess with my cousin and he pointed
and I see this other sweet kid who like
tried to teach me to skate earlier just
like kind of like avoid eye contact and
I go ah I go whoo and he goes you heard
me and I was like no one ever had ever
said you heard me before and I [ __ ]
myself and I go yes
and he goes yeah no no I didn't mean to
sir
I it is like you mess with him and if
you mess with him again I'm gonna kick
your ass
Eddie's like and I'm here every weekend
and I was like this is the one roller
rink on our side of town so like every
kid that summer had their birthday party
at this roller rink and I had to say no
to all of them I was too afraid to ever
go back and I never learn to
roller-skate
[Laughter]
you heard me use the biggest kid I feel
like now anytime I see kids on roller
skates or skateboards down beat his ass
that is our so reminder that you could
join our official disk or gonna becoming
a patron at patreon.com slash new rock
stars you can get an audio version of
the show by subscribing to our new
rockstars big question podcasts where
every year podcast thanks everyone who
submitted questions getting mail as
questions as well hey thanks Tommy
Bechtold
for being an amazing co-host as always
thanks for having me Eric pleasure is
always great to get to know more
interesting things about you and to
reveal more humiliating things about
myself hey where does we're getting
closer and closer and we're doing the
the zoom call version of the weird
sensible handshake at how the verbal
part gets so screwed up John yeah I'm
sorry but did you like it how much do I
owe you now follow Tommy at Tommy
Bechtold on all social media you can
follow me at ya bas on instagram and on
twitter you can follow a new Roxanna
social subscribe here on YouTube to get
too much information on all the stuff
you care about and hey in honor of this
being a tenant episode
SANDAG I saw her we've a server when he
was a server in the door oh did you get
that Tommy did I understand what's going
I God wasn't good for you it was great
[Music]